You guys are truly going to be disgusted by
what I'm going to tell you today.
Last week, I already told you that we have
been 100 percent demagnetized on Facebook.
We are making zero point zero on Facebook
because I talked about the fact that former
Trump advisor Steve Bannon.
Right.
Wingnut suggested Dr. Fauci be beheaded.
OK, we didn't show any gory videos.
We called him out for saying it.
We called out the violent rhetoric from the
right against doctors.
We were reporting on it and we were 100 percent
demonetization Facebook, our entire channel.
We've come to build our Facebook revenue.
It's about 17, 18 percent of our monthly revenue.
It's gone.
OK, I told you that last week.
That's already bad enough.
And the right loves to say, oh, the social
platforms are all left wing.
They oppress the right and they favor the
left and blah, blah, blah.
But we are banned from monetizing every video
on Facebook because I mentioned what Steve
Bannon said.
OK, here is the new wrinkle.
Mark Zuckerberg has decided Facebook won't
be banning Steve Bannon because of that video
that he posted because he hasn't done anything
bad enough to be ban worthy.
Reuters reports.
Zuckerberg defends not suspending X Trump
aide Bannon from Facebook.
And it goes on to say that Facebook chief
executive Mark Zuckerberg said on Thursday.
Trump White House adviser, former Trump White
House adviser Steve Bannon didn't violate
enough of their policies to suspend him from
Facebook when he urged the beheading of two
senior U.S. officials.
I really need everybody to understand this.
What Steve Bannon said about Dr. Fauci is
supposedly so bad, so vile, so horrible, so
toxic that I was one hundred percent monetized
for mentioning Bannon said this and it's bad.
But the person who actually said the horrible,
vile thing for which I was the monetized,
he didn't do anything worthy of being banned
from Facebook, Facebook, which Republicans
love to hate.
And like all major social media networks,
they claim Facebook favors the left, Facebook
hates the right.
They ended my monetization for criticizing
what Steve Bannon said.
But Mark Zuckerberg says the guy who said
it now, he didn't do anything bad worthy.
Give me a break.
Come on, guys.
It's almost satirical that it's so absurd.
Update on monetization is we are still, as
of this moment, one hundred percent de monetized.
Some people wrote to me saying they have contacts
at Facebook.
They have some emails in.
Others, said, David, monetization might return
automatically after a week or potentially
thirty days.
I will let you know in any case, we this is
why we are working on building direct support
so we're not knocked around by this stuff.
Grab a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We have this coupon code.
Fresh start saves you seventy percent and
every membership protects us from this type
of nonsense.
So please do grab a membership at join AskMen.com
and I will certainly let you know if Facebook
monetization ever returns.